normalement le moment du thé chez la
famille à paris est beaucoup plus
heureux
[Musique]
chaque personne assise à cette table
craint de perdre un proche en
afghanistan depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
des talibans c'est très difficile parce
que tout en un petit peu quand je
regarde les nouvelles ce que tu entends
tu es comme écoute moi je suis ici je
suis en sécurité bien des gens que je
connais la boxe sont pas en sécurité
puis ça fait
peut pas aidé non plus tu peux rien
faire shoaib comme tous les membres de
sa famille appartient à une minorité
ethnique appelé à zohra fortement
persécutés en afghanistan depuis des
siècles à la fin des années 90 son père
a été sévèrement battu par les talibans
ce qui a motivé l'exil de sa famille de
ses oncles fuyant aussi les violences
étaient déjà ici ils sont arrivés le 11
ou 2006 c'est sûr que c'était difficile
qu'on est revenu au canada parce que on
parlait pas de la langue comme la
plupart des immigrants ils ont dû
repartir à zéro les deux frères ont
commencé à travailler comme plongeur
dans un restaurant de sherbrooke quinze
ans plus tard ils sont très bien ancré
dans la culture rom et fier de québécois
avec un ca viennent dans notre corps ils
sont maintenant propriétaires de 27
restaurants à déjeuner les coucous
frutti une bannière qui l'ont créée à la
sueur de leur front en 2014
mais dernièrement n'aurait habib n'ont
pas la tête à travailler pour leur
entreprise
l'arrivée des talibans à kaboul fut une
journée très sombre c'était terrible
pour nos autres membres ont maillé
larmont en collier déjà là comme on
sonne c'est hulk et nathalie basnier
perry kaboul pour moitié à bille
c'était une journée peut-être pour les
autres c'est et noir comme les nuits
pour nos autres c'est plus que ça parce
qu'on a pensé qu est ce qu'on doit faire
il consacre maintenant la majorité de
leur temps à essayer de sauver leurs
proches d'autant plus que plusieurs
membres de leur famille ont aidé les
forces armées canadiennes
à ce jour aucune réponse fille ciel de
la part du gouvernement seulement des
accusés de réception on a envie de
courir partout
pour être capable de l'aider les gens
fassent quand on sait que leur vie en
danger parmi les gens qui le temps de
faire venir au canada [ __ ] aux nabis
zada un ami de longue date du clan
familial l'homme et journalistes
fondateurs de l'entreprise médiatique
pro-démocratie kama presse et
dernièrement chef de bureau pour le
ministère de la paix
aidé par l'armée américaine il a pu fuir
le pays le 19 ou après s'être caché chez
un ami
la journée que les talibans sont entrés
à kaboul je ne savais pas où aller ou me
cacher je savais que ma vie était en
danger je suis encore traumatisée par
une récente attaque à la bombe
en février dernier les talibans ont
tenté de le tuer alors qu'il est au
volant de sa voiture avec ses deux
enfants il se trouve maintenant dans un
camp de réfugiés en allemagne avec sa
famille en sécurité
je ne suis pas du tout optimiste pour la
suite des choses plusieurs personnes
sont torturés et les taliban entre deux
forces dans les maisons il n'a aucune
idée où il sera demain mais s'accroche à
l'espoir de venez rejoindre sa famille
et ses amis ici il attend impatiemment
une réponse du gouvernement canadien ça
ce n'est pas facile de tout laisser
derrière mais pour sauver ma vie je
n'avais pas le choix son employée mise
en réserve et lui n'a pas eu cette
chance dans mon bain je suis
présentement caché chez moi parce que je
suis journaliste et j'ai écrit plusieurs
articles ou de critiquer ouvertement les
talibans
la semaine dernière il a demandé à ses
gestionnaires de supprimer une vingtaine
de ses articles mais l'angoissé est
toujours là
il recherche présentement des gens comme
moi je suis une cible je suis très
inquiet ils peuvent retrouver mes
articles sur internet je suis en danger
il se cache donc derrière les murs de sa
maison avec sa femme et sa petite fille
de 8 mois et tentent de fuir le pays
lueur d'espoir qui devient par contre de
plus en plus minces eux pour nizam le
canada où il pourrait rejoindre ses deux
soeurs à toronto il atteint lui aussi
une réponse du gouvernement canadien
puis punch et ne pas faire les gens
doivent savoir ce qui se passe ici oui
ma vie est en danger parce que je vous
parle me dire la vérité est crucial par
dessus tout le sort réservé aux femmes
lui fait faire des cauchemars
s'il m'arrive quelque chose personne
pourra protéger ma femme et ma fille et
ça m'inquiète énormément la famille
akbari implore le gouvernement de ne pas
quitter l'afghanistan le 31 août et
d'accueillir plus de réfugiés la
situation est critique le danger est
imminent moi je suis
pas content non seulement comme on est
très
chaude du haut de ses 24 ans en a gros
sur ses épaules il faut les aider pin ou
tout seul match peut rien faire